Hôm nay 1 tháng 3 năm 2018, các quan cạnh rất đều trạc công an thành phố Chímin đang đều trạc vụ chết người chứ gió miên nhìn tại Tổ Bà,
Cố vô tình hạnh phần phủ Mỹ, Tế Phố Chímin.
Chứ đó, khoảng 12,5-2 năm 2018, người dân sọn có tại dự ăn,
cùng nhà ở công nghiênh Thì với hiện thi tiện người nơi chính bảo công an.
Nạn nhân được sất liện là năm dưới, khoảng 28,000 tuổi,
cao khoảng 1 phía bệnh mết trong tình trọng phân truyền nặng mất một tính tay phải.
Tại hiện chứ, các quan cạnh nặng thu dữ một đôi dế mẫu xanh nước viện,
tình trạc thàn thoá, ba mạnh kìm loại tình trạc thàn thoá, một mũ bà hiểm mổn.
A là người thân của Nạn nhân, phó có người mức tích giống các đặc điểm như trên hãy lên hiện các quan cạnh rất đều trạc công an thành phố Chímin.
số 15 đường trường chiến, phương bà dịt, khoảng nước hiện đều trạc viên hình tình đặt,
số định thải khóc chiến 8 bún, một chiến 8 bệnh không không để phối học sẽ quyết.